-My first guest tonight
is a hip-hop legend
and one of the biggest
entertainers in the world.
You can see him
in the new show "BMF,"
which airs Sundays at 8:00 p.m.
on Starz,
and he lends his voice
to the new animated movie
"The Addams Family 2,"
which is in theaters on Friday.
Here is Snoop Dogg, everybody.
That's what I'm talking about,
yeah.
That's exactly
what I'm talking about.
You look good, buddy.
Welcome.
-What's up, Jimmy?
What's happening?
-I'm so happy
you came back to the show.
Happy almost 50th birthday?
Are you turning 50?
-Yeah, I'm about to be 5-0, man.
-Wow, you're about to be 5-0.
And doing anything special
for the birthday?
I'm assuming.
-Yeah, my wife
is throwing a party for me,
a players ball
for my 50th birthday party,
so, you know, we're gonna be
suited in booty,
You know what I'm saying?
Ready to do what we do.
-Yeah.
That's -- And how --
I wanted to ask you this
question because I never have.
I think when people
hang out with you,
they think that they
should smoke weed with you
or try to smoke or keep up
with you, I think.
Is that true?
Do people just go up to you
and go, "Let's go for it?
Let's see if I can keep up
with Snoop Dogg?"
-I mean, I filled a lot
of hospital beds
with those kind of people,
Jimmy.
Like, this is a grown-man sport.
I'm a heavyweight, so --
-I know.
That's exactly right.
-When you step in the ring,
you got to be prepared
for all things,
and, I mean, a lot of times
people want to do it,
but until they get in the ring
and they really understand
what they're getting into.
-Yeah, I would never
even go near the ring.
I would -- Yeah.
I know you too well.
I wouldn't even remotely go near
that, but I know -- I heard --
-You know when I come down
to your show in real life,
when I'm really there,
I blow the room out,
you be trying to move me
to different floors
and move me far away from y'all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
That is exactly --
That is so true
that I can't believe it.
We actually try to have you
on a different floor
because everyone has to
work here, you know?
I get worried.
I get worried about --
I want to talk to you about --
You just joined Def Jam
as an executive creative
and strategic consultant.
Snoop Dogg at Def Jam.
I love this idea, but how
and why did you want this?
-Well, I was a fan
of Def Jam Records as a kid,
and, you know, knowing
the talent they have over there
and the opportunity
that was waiting on me,
I wanted to go over there
and give a lot of opportunity
to the artists over there to get
some information, some wisdom,
and some guidance from me
and then also develop
some new acts
and give some opportunities,
so Def Jam was the perfect place
for me
considering how much I love it
and how much it means to hip-hop
and how it really needed
somebody like me
to come and change the energy
of the building.
So I'm over there
for one reason --
to get the music back popping
and to make people feel
like they're supposed to feel.
-I love that you're at Def Jam.
I love Def Jam.
Such an important part of music.
Does that maybe hint at, maybe,
a new Snoop Dogg album? No?
-Yeah, we got an album
coming out.
It's called "Algorithm."
It'll be out in November.
And it's featuring a lot of
big-name acts and some new ones.
Yes, sir.
-Whoa.
That was more info than
I thought I was going to get.
I thought you were just
going to go, "Yeah, maybe."
-Oh, yeah, also, Jimmy,
I got a Def Jam kids album
coming out this year, too,
something for the kids,
so, you know,
we thinking about
those babies, too.
-That's why I love you, man.
We talked last time
you were on the show --
We were saying, "What would you
be if you weren't a rapper?"
And I was trying to --
I guessed that you
would be a gamer.
I thought that might be
what you would be,
but you said that
you would be a pastor.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and --
[ Laughter ]
And now here's --
-Some of the best preachers
come from this --
from the wrong side
to the right side.
That's why I say that,
because when you tested,
you give a testimony,
and most preachers that are
very good at what they do
have the best testimonies
because they've been
through the storm,
they've been through the worst,
and they can give you
understanding and explanation
to what you're going through and
what you're about to go through.
-Yeah, well,
I totally agree with you.
That is actually --
That's correct.
But in this new show "BMF,"
you actually play a pastor.
And I was like, "He did it.
He dreamed it."
-I'm a manifester, Jimmy.
I'm one of those guys
that they call a manifester,
so I manifested it.
-Manifester, dude.
-I spoke on it,
and it came to life.
-You did.
What does "BMF" stand for?
-Black Mafia Family.
-Yeah.
-That's an organization that was
very, very popular in Atlanta
in the early 2000s,
and Detroit is where
they originated.
There were brothers
who started in the drug trade
and made it very famous
and launched a lot of careers,
and they were part of culture,
style, fashion,
and their story
is damn sure worth seeing.
It's on the Starz network
on Sunday nights,
and you can check it out.
-Yeah, I'll definitely
check it out.
I love that, man.
But then here's what
I love about you.
You do that,
and then this Friday,
my kids cannot wait to see this.
"Addams Family 2" is coming out
in theaters this Friday.
You are the voice of Cousin Itt.
[ Laughter ]
No, you got to give --
you got to give --
You entertain everybody.
All ages.
-You know what, Jimmy?
I think I'm a big kid.
I think we all have
a little bit of kid in us.
We just don't know
how to express it.
I have a fun way of doing it
by saying that I'm
the biggest kid in the room,
and I don't mind, you know,
tapping into my kid side,
so when I do things
like "The Addams Family"
and get a chance to tap into
doing voices for something
that I know the kids
are going to be affected by,
it makes knee feel good to know
that I can enter
into their world
and do something clean enough
for them to, you know,
actually be able to watch
and listen to.
-Yep, there you go.
You always do.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Snoop Dogg
in "The Addams Family 2."
Take a look at this.
-Ah, there he is.
The man we came to see.
[ Hip-hop music playing ]
♪♪
-♪ What the ladies say? ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Ladies,
what the ladies say? ♪
♪ Ladies, what the ladies say? ♪
♪ Yeah, Dogg, we got your back ♪
♪ Where my homies at? ♪
♪ Homies,
where the gangsters at? ♪
♪ Gangsters,
♪ Yeah, Dogg, we got your back ♪
♪ We own it like we want it ♪
♪ We beat it till we be it ♪
♪ And only you
can give it to us ♪
♪ 'Cause you know we need it ♪
-It's good to see you,
my bewhiskered cousin.
You made it.
-[ Chattering ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Chatters ]
Snoop Dogg, everybody.
"The Addams Family 2"
is in theaters on Friday.
And "BMF" airs Sunday nights
at 8:00 p.m. on Starz.